another body washed up far from home
the latest casualty of the Shipwreck of
the Southern Italian Coast
along the shoreline the remains of the
vessel all too evident as the sea
continued to churn out the splintered
wreckage
at least 180 people have been packed
into the wooden sailboat according to
local authorities
most of them from Afghanistan Iran and
Pakistan 14 children were among those
who drowned after it crashed onto the
rocks and sank near the town of staccato
ricotro
strong winds and rough Seas hampered the
rescue efforts
and those who survived remain distraught
and still in shock from the traumatic
ordeal
nearby the dead were placed into coffins
then transferred to a sports Hall where
many came to pay their respects
there are no words one can only stand
beside the survivors and tend to their
basic needs
to date this has been the deadliest
migrant disaster since 127 people died
after drowning off the coast of Syria in
September last year
Italy has seen a sharp rise in arrivals
of undocumented migrants this past year
despite the Prime Minister JoJo
Maloney's vow to reduce them
a promise that has been made for years
and won Italy's interior Minister
insists should be implemented at the
origin countries of such Crossings
the fact is that when there are these
conditions you shouldn't leave if we
don't say to the world and to the
territories from which these people
leave this ethical message ethical above
all you shouldn't leave you shouldn't
expose women and children to dangerous
conditions
from the ongoing migration debate
the Italian president has urged the
European Union to take Collective
responsibility and tackle the ongoing
issue of the human traffickers profiting
from such treacherous Journeys
Al Jazeera